[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today
yeah we wasn't hanging out what's up
guys we're just hanging out too how can
we help
so 15 years ago my husband and I go to
get married and he is very adamant he
does not want to combine funds
absolutely not we're going to school
everything 50 50 from our separate
accounts
so okay great now 15 years later I now
make three times his income I've worked
really hard to get myself out of debt
and now he wants to combine fines
and I'm really struggling with accepting
that after I've put in all the hard work
and time to say okay
all right can I how honest can I be with
you
as honest as you want
this is not the main issue in your
marriage and you know that and your
marriage is on real thin ice true or
false yeah true true very true this is a
periphery issue that's way outside
the the
um contempt with which you're talking
about your husband tells me there's way
bigger issues going on here
Fair
yeah money will take care of itself
joining finances is something we like I
I I can't wrap my head around making a
kid and not trusting my spouse like
making a human with my wife but not
trusting her enough to share accounts I
can't wrap my head around that so we do
tell people man if you want to be
unified join accounts this isn't that
situation yet that kind of stuff often
takes care of itself not always but
often you guys got bigger fish tell me
what's going on man
I honestly don't know I think um
trying to
reach them and it shouldn't be I should
be weak at trying to reach them yeah
no it felt really alone I would say
it's always been almost a roommate like
we live here and we've
we just live
that's the single most that's the single
most used word I hear behind closed
doors sitting with couples
we're roommates
or they laugh and try to chuckle the
tears away and say like we're Michael
Scott and Jim when we're co-managers of
our house right but that's about it sure
there's no intimacy there's no we're not
both working towards this goal out there
that we're going to go get it is I'm
gonna do my stuff I'll get my report
turned in on time he didn't do his
report on time and now I got to do his
his work that is I mean that is a recipe
for resentment and a relationship to end
up in Ash
if it's not there already
yeah and this is the moment when
somebody at work is hilarious
and they text you a meme and you text
back and then they text back and then
you text back and then a few days later
you're turning your phone over when your
husband walks in the room or vice versa
that's this moment right now if it's not
already Fair
sure it's not there I know I get what
you're saying yeah but maybe right so
um 15 years ago I'm just curious 15
years ago did you want to combine money
and it was just him that was like no or
were you like I'm good with being
separate
you know um I wanted to but at the same
time I came from nothing at the time I
was in school I had a car payment
because I was an idiot at 18 bought a
brand new car
um so I was like you know what I totally
get it I'll I'll pay my half and I'm
responsible for myself fine
um so is he is he just a deadbeat why do
you resent him so much okay let me ask
this you don't like him why
I I don't know is he controlling him I
know you love him I know I don't
question about judgmental you don't like
um
I think he doesn't understand he was
born more privileged which is great but
he does he discounts the hard work that
everybody else has to put in and so now
that I'm somewhere he's not it's
oh well now this is part mine and we've
earned it and it's like well no you
didn't come to school with me and you
didn't take care of the house while I
was gone I did all of this yeah y'all
are in a mess man um you all need to
make an appointment with the marriage
counselor by the end of next week
okay and I need you to be honest and
strong and bold as strong as you are
presenting to us right now you need to
be that strong in a therapy session and
say those words out loud that you just
said here that's right
otherwise that's just going to fester
and I mean it already has we hear it
you don't like him you think he is a
scam he is like a mooch off of you and
you think over the last 15 years you've
worked harder than him and his life has
been easier than yours and he just
doesn't understand how hard work is that
might be a hundred percent true and it
might not be and the reality is it
doesn't matter because you believe it
and you cannot have intimacy if you are
one-upping or one Downing your spouse
all the time and he might be doing the
exact same thing with you and maybe he
is a total mooch just
feed up Netflix on you know tall boy in
his hand waiting on Mama to bring home
the paycheck and suddenly this is all
ours maybe that's him I think it was in
the beginning he viewed himself up here
and she needed to reach that standard
right yeah and then when she blew pastry
whatever standard he created and she
accepted then it's like oh well wait a
minute
now I get to now now it's enough and now
I want to be part of it and now she's
it's almost like now you're doing the
same thing he did in the beginning the
table's turned
yeah and I don't want that I really
genuinely am trying to live for a more
Godly relationship a Godly marriage but
I just can't get over the frustration
and good so even in the conversation now
it's not I want us to be one I want us
to enjoy all of this together and work
hard to you know get better it's well
now you make more than me so I don't
have to worry about you spending all of
my money well that's not trust that's
not a marriage that's not a marriage
that's not even a good friend yeah I
guess I'm a good buddy there's remember
back in like high school there's always
that one guy that's like no bro you owe
me 436 because I got the Wendy's combo
last time that that's that annoying guy
and then there's also that other buddy
that's like no dude I got it no I got it
I got it and the fist fights were almost
who was gonna pay not who wasn't like
that's mirror yeah that's marriage
um
so
the great Esther perel talks about gave
a very beautiful elegant picture that I
want you to hold tight okay here's the
picture it was talking she was talking
about a couple that had um one of them
had cheated on the other one
and she said the most damaging thing is
couples all whenever something like that
happens there's a fracture in the
relationship they always want to go back
to what was remember when right
and she gave us a very beautiful picture
she says you could not go on September
12th the day after the Twin Towers fell
and sweep up all the glass and steel and
wood and all of that mess and use those
same materials and rebuild the towers
they fell they fell you have two choices
you let them sit and let nature take it
back over or you get some professionals
in there you excavate it you create
something new so I want to tell you the
relationship that y'all have had is over
your choice now is do we walk away or do
we work together and do whatever it
takes to build something new get in with
a marriage therapist ASAP stay on the
line and hook you up with better help
that will help you all get in I'll give
you three free months to just get
started call somebody today your
marriage is in crisis we'll be right
back